luego de un golpe de estado-militar
guinea conakry ya tiene nuevo presidente
interino el joven coronel mamady tumbó
ya juramento este viernes su cargo luego
de liderar el pasado 5 de septiembre el
derrocamiento de su predecesor alpha
condé que gobernó el país desde 2010
soy plenamente consciente del alcance y
la inmensidad de los intercambios que se
me han encomendado en calidad de
presidente de la transición jefe de
estado la transición gft l está en su
discurso de investidura al joven un goya
apeló a su deseo de reconciliación y
justicia para el pueblo guineano uno de
los más empobrecidos del continente
africano asolado por la corrupción y la
mala gestión de sus gobernantes se
misión sobre sí mismo es anselma a
estas misiones se reducen esencialmente
a la redacción de una nueva constitución
la refundación del et a la refundación
del estado la lucha contra la corrupción
la reforma del sistema electoral forma y
sistema electoral y la refundición del
expediente la organización de elecciones
libres creíbles y transparentes y la
reconciliación nacional creativa y
transparentes
en la reconciliación nacional
originario de la etnia malinké la
segunda más grande de la nación paso por
la legión extranjera y cursó estudios
superiores de guerra en francia israel
senegal y gabón el líder golpista
reiteró también su compromiso de
respetar la carta de transición no
participar en los próximos comicios sin
especificar la fecha él
hizo un juramento ante el pueblo de
guinea prometió no postularse en las
próximas elecciones ni él ni otros que
formarán parte del gobierno de
transición no tengo ninguna razón para
dudar en su buena fe szostak la
ceremonia se celebró en el palacio
presidencial y estuvo marcada por la
ausencia de la mayoría de los jefes de
estado de áfrica occidental que han
acordado imponer sanciones a los
miembros de la junta militar de sus
familiares